I would go into agencies and there would
be closets of computers and printers and
everything they would do and so we
started incentivizing agencies to give
money back to the taxpayers so you know
when you go in there what they do is oh
we need more people for this we need
more people for that you add a new
program that's not adding a person
that's adding 25 more people that's the
growth of government and so at some
point you go into every agency you look
at every program and say what was the
intent is it still needed I did that in
the United Nations I went into every
single
um one of the peacekeeping operations we
had and I said what was the original
intent are we complaining and what's our
exit strategy because they had no exit
strategies to any of them we saved three
billion dollars the first year it's just
about putting some good approaches in
place that make sure that they're
actually meeting the intended goal to
start with and if there is no goal
anymore you scrap that program you scrap
the people that go with it and that's
how you clean an agency and then you go
and you put in something where anybody
that's in a role they can only serve in
it four to five years and then they roll
to a different position or another
position you never let them sit for that
long
foreign
Rubin and welcome to the first episode
of the path to the presidency over the
coming months I'm going to be
interviewing all of the declared
Republican presidential candidates and
if some Democrats get in I guess we
could do that too and joining me to kick
this off is the former governor of South
Carolina the former U.S ambassador to
the United Nations and now Republican
candidate for president of the United
States Nikki Haley Nikki nice to see you
thanks for the chat I appreciate it all
right you're first out of all of the
people well you were
technically you weren't first in right
Donald Trump was first in your second
Inn but you're first with me which I
would imagine is yes probably more
important yes you know I mean look I'm a
decisive person I didn't need to wait I
didn't need to wait to see who else was
going to get in I didn't need to wait or
worry about anything else I think if
you're gonna do this you have to do it
because you know this is what you want
and you know this is what you think you
can do for the country and so we were
ready and you know it's been a month and
it's been a whirlwind but we're working
and all is good what were the biggest
things holding you back before
announcing or the biggest worries we'll
get into the reasons why you're running
obviously but like what was the stuff
that you were going maybe I shouldn't do
it it's always only family I mean family
is the only reason that you you know
you've got this
when you when you know you can fix
something
like it just itches at you and really
after the midterms I was like that's it
that's it you know I mean it it's how
much more do you sit back and watch and
I've always been a problem solver and I
know what we need to do I've been a
two-term governor that took double-digit
unemployment state and turned it into an
economic Powerhouse I was at the U.N I
didn't deal with one country I dealt
with 193 and took the kick me sign off
of our back and I look at where our
country is and I see us falling into
this socialism and defeatism and you
know there's not an Avenue that we don't
have serious issues with and I'm
thinking you know I'm gonna do this and
you know it goes back to the fact that I
look at my parents they came here 50
years ago when America was strong and
confident and full of opportunities I
want to prove to them that they made the
right decision you know I'm a military
wife and I've watched my husband and his
brothers and sisters go out and fight
for our freedoms I want them to know
their sacrifice matter did it mean
something and I look at my kids and my
daughter's getting married and I see how
hard it is for her to buy a home and my
son is in college and I see him writing
papers he doesn't believe in to get an A
and none of us should be okay with that
and recently 50 percent of Americans
said that they don't think their
children will live a better life than
them I refuse to let that happen to this
great country I just refuse it so I'm
going to get in there and do something
about are you shocked how quickly things
have changed for the worse I mean if you
take Trump's term before covid things
were good the economy was chugging along
we weren't in extemporaneous Wars like
things seem to be moving nicely and then
in these last two years and especially
just this last you know week and a half
with all of this banking stuff it's like
everything feels unsettled right now
well when you have a weak president when
you have the most socialist president
that we've ever had that's what's going
to happen you know America's not strong
on our own we have to actually work at
it and that's the part I hope that
Americans take away is it's going to
take every single one of us to fix this
and in order to do that you've got to
realize a lot of things have gone wrong
and Dave it wasn't just the Democrats
that did this to us there are no saint
Republicans right now because you look
at Congress and all of this inflation
all the economic issues that started
with Republicans that 2.2 trillion
dollar stimulus package that was passed
Republicans started Democrats have just
run with it after that but then what did
Republicans do after that so first they
do this free-for-all they expand welfare
so we now have 90 million people on
Medicare 42 million people on food
stamps so they expand welfare and then
oh it's bad so what else do Republicans
do open up earmarks after 10 years like
what do you make of that because when
every time so Republicans usually say
we're for small government we're for low
taxes and every now and again someone
does cut taxes but when something like
the Omnibus comes and they sign on to
all of these crazy things and you know
nobody's read the bill and they know
what we're all going to say about it yet
they keep doing it is that is that to
you just like the definition of what the
swamp is I mean don't tell me that
Republicans and Democrats don't agree on
anything because they love to waste
taxpayer money and they have no value
for a dollar it's why I think we have to
have term limits that's why I think we
have to have mandatory mental competency
tests over the age of 75. I mean this is
serious and then you look at the fact
that our debt is higher than our economy
we're having to borrow money to make our
interest payments I mean none of this is
okay and so Republicans love to get on
TV and talk about how awful Biden is
they started it so don't don't do that
but we can put an end to it and that's
the key and you know now they're looking
at what's going to happen with the
economy and Biden of course wants to
just keep raising taxes but what should
they be doing call back the 500 billion
in coveted money that hasn't been spent
don't put IRS agents on middle class
Americans go and get that 100 billion in
covid fraud that happened you know if 15
of our budget is interest stop borrowing
money we don't do that at home as
Governor I had to balance a budget at
what point is Congress going to realize
they are not the only body that gets
exempt from how they spend are you
telling me if we uh increase the the
deficit and the ceiling the the debt
ceiling every year or two years or
whatever that that might cause a
long-term problem am I am I following
you properly I mean look at our
households yeah we don't spend more than
we make because we can't be pretty sweet
if you could just always up that credit
limit it's amazing to me truly and and I
mean Republican can't say they're
conservative you're not conservative if
you're spending like that and look I've
dealt with that in South Carolina we had
a republican House a Republican Senate
and they didn't see anything they didn't
that they didn't love to spend on and we
called them out on it we called out Port
projects we called out the fact that we
had to pay down debt we went and gave
tax cuts like you've got to be proactive
and say enough and I think Republicans
have to realize look yeah we can bash
the Democrats they they have been awful
they're socialist it's it's terrible but
let's look in the mirror look in the
mirror and republicans in Congress need
to say but what responsibility do we
take do you fear ever that the cultural
War has has been so lost that even if
you have all of the right ideas right so
we can talk about individual rights and
limited government and Free Speech all
of the right stuff that the cultural
part of this is so messed up and so many
people don't understand what the real
issues are and kind of just do want the
government to do everything that it
almost becomes an unwinnable situation
for Republican like if you look at the
midterms it's like the Republicans
obviously should have won and yet people
were basically like well the Democrats
are running everything it's not that
good but I'm not going to vote for
Republican but I don't think that's what
happened I mean I Endure 70 candidates
we raise 10 million dollars that went
directly into campaign accounts I was on
the ground campaigning I think you had
three things that went wrong I think
first of all you saw Democrats outraged
Republicans again you saw the fact that
Republicans have to get it out of their
heads that you you have to vote on
Election Day if you have legal voting
times we need as many of our people at
the voting booth as we can eat when as
long as it's legal I want every person
to vote because we need every single one
and then finally when Independence and
conservative Democrats who weren't happy
with Biden by the way won't what'd they
see they saw Republicans hitting on each
other and hitting on Democrats it looked
like chaos
we have to go back to what our national
purpose is we've got to stop this
National self-loathing that's at the
heart of the culture wars and what
started it stop this idea that comlin
Biden loved to say that America is
rotten and that we're racist and they
weren't terrible to the Core
we have to go back to loving America
again because right now we look so
distracted and when America is
distracted the world is less safe we're
seeing that but the national
self-loathing I want our kids to love
America I want our kids to start saying
the Pledge of Allegiance in the morning
and at school I want our kids to
understand that this is the greatest
country in the world we have to do that
and so I think that's the first thing is
let's let's stop all this craziness and
let's go back to showing what loving
America means and that's not with faint
hearts or watered-down compromises
that's by truly proclaiming what we
believe in and then our opponents will
join us and then the other side is if
Republicans have lost the last seven out
of eight popular votes for president
shouldn't we say maybe we're doing
something wrong shouldn't we want to win
the majority of America
because our Solutions are the right ones
we focus on lifting up everybody not a
select few but how we communicate it
matters uh one of the three things that
you just mentioned there the the let's
talk about the second one for a second
the the voting situation because the
Democrats obviously do ballot harvesting
all of this stuff you know Trump is is
basically running on that they stole the
election from him last time are you
confident that there would be a
situation where states that are still
doing this stuff so that you know I know
you don't have to worry about say a
Florida or uh you know another or Texas
or South Carolina or South Carolina for
example right but I should have said
South Carolina got it um but how worried
are you that California that
Pennsylvania the states that are doing
all of this crazy stuff no IDs no
signature match all that would even
allow for an honest and fair election
well first of all I passed voter ID in
2011 and was vilified for it by the way
I mean the Press said I was
disenfranchising voters they thought it
was terrible and at the time I put the
marker down and I said if you think
anyone can't get to the DM V we will go
pick them up you put money we will take
them to the DMV we will give them a free
ID and we'll return them home 25 people
out of 5 million asked for a ride yeah
yeah so you know one I think voter ID
needs to be the law of the land that's
not a republican issue all people want
to know that their their vote is who it
but what do you do about that before 24
because for Cali for example it's not
going to do it no it's tough right and I
think the worst part of it's the
mail-out balloting I mean that's the
part that I think is that the harvesting
I think Republicans are too nice
Republicans have always been too nice we
need to step up and play the game within
the rules but also call out anything
that we see is wrong it doesn't mean we
say Oh California is always going to do
it you call it out no matter what we're
going to force these states to have to
do it right because if you can get the
people to say it I mean 73 of Americans
say that they think you should have to
show your ID in order to vote that
includes Democrats we need to start
messaging that better and say don't let
them to take your rights away don't you
want to know that there's Integrity to
this process it's not going to be easy
yeah it's incredible because most people
do agree you have to have an ID to buy a
bottle of wine and for some reason you
don't have to to vote you also mentioned
the cognitive test so I have to ask you
about the Don Lemon brouhaha we can do
it in two seconds but basically he said
you're not in your Prime and I said hold
my beer I am definitely in my Prime you
know we made Koozies out of it and it
said not my Prime hole my beer we sold
thirty thousand dollars worth of
Jacuzzis in 24 hours so we literally
made lemonade out of lemons I mean look
God bless him but I have always made
liberals heads explode from the very
first time I ran for the State House
even
they can't stand the fact that a
minority female would be a conservative
they can't take it and you know even
when I became Governor there was a
senior African-American female Democrat
and when I became governor and they were
celebrating that I was the first
female minority governor in history
she went and she said she's not a
minority she's just a conservative with
a tan like this has always been an issue
and so for Don Lemon to sit there and do
that you know Whoopi Goldberg had done
it the day before I know I know there
will be one was actually worse even you
know I mean and then the guy on MSNBC
like you know just sit there and say
that I was like ex trying to show white
supremacy or whatever they'll say
whatever but it none of that phases me
because I know they're worried they know
that I pull from their base they know
that I pull on women they know I pull in
minorities and they have always been
scared by that and so I I know that that
means I'm a threat and I'll take it do
you feel that that's like the key part
of your campaign that you'll be able to
get some of the crossover people because
I was talking about my show there's not
that many people willing to move right
like we sort of know how many people are
going to vote for each side and it's
always about getting that Fringe I
always say it's the to me it's the
disaffected Liberals it's the me of five
years ago that are like wait the
Democrats are completely insane but
could I actually vote for a republican
do you feel like that's sort of your so
the interesting thing is the reason that
I'm a hardcore conservative so I'm not
pulling them over because there's a
moderate side to me it's because of how
I communicate with them you know
Republicans need to see this as a story
of addition we need Asians we need the
Jewish Community we need the Hispanics
we need women we need African Americans
but you don't go to them and say you
should be with us you go to them and say
what do you care about guess what every
one of them cares about their kids every
one of them cares about opportunities
for their kids that they didn't have
every one of them wants a safe America
that's strong abroad my parents were
Democrats until Reagan not because they
were really Democrats but because
Republicans wouldn't talk to them I just
talked to them I go and talk to them I
talk about conservative issues but I do
it through their lens and when you know
what their fears are and you can talk
about conservative Solutions through
their fears they come over that's what
Republicans should want to have happen
we don't have to compromise but you do
have to communicate to people that don't
look and sound like you what's your
policy going to be when it comes to the
media I mean obviously you've got Trump
loves fighting with the media you have
DeSantis who's basically saying I'm
going to ignore media that won't treat
us fairly
you're it seems like you're willing to
go in and play with them but you know
you're not going to get a fair shake you
know if you're on MSNBC or whatever it
might be I mean I'm gonna go do any TV
because if you're trying to win the
hearts and minds of America you've got
to go everywhere but if they say
something's wrong I'm gonna kick back
you know I mean I think that you have to
you really have to do that and I I did
that I think one of my first interviews
was with um The Today Show and you know
Craig Melvin he was pushing back and I
pushed back as hard as he gave it
because I know that my answers were true
and they just want to change the
narrative you know a lot of the liberal
media the hate that they have on me is
they either want me to love Trump 100 or
hate Trump right right I don't I'm not
100 with my husband all the time like
you know but when President Trump would
do something good of course I support it
of course I praised him of course we did
but if he does something wrong I'm going
to call him out too I've always been
like that I've always been a truth
teller in that way and so you know I'll
keep handling it that same way so
actually let's talk about that for a
moment so it seems like there's a
certain set of the Trump Bass that
thinks that you either abandoned him or
something like that I think we talked
about this once off camera so I'll just
tee it up for you to take it away from
there I mean look I had a great working
relationship with him he is a friend I
called him before I decided to run
um we I love what we were able to do
together I think he was the right
president at the right time
um but when and in the administration
when I was there he would do something
great I'd support him if he'd do
something wrong I'd say you can't do
this and I'd give him options did he
appreciate that he did there was a great
respect between us and he would always
say well how do you see that playing out
we had a great working relationship but
when I see something wrong I'm going to
call it I didn't think he handled
January 6th well I called it out I stand
by that so you know those that don't
like that fact that I called him out
that's exactly what I did when I was in
the administration that's exactly what I
do to my friends that's exactly what
I'll do going forward and he knows that
about me is any of the stuff that has
been played on Tucker in the tapes and
any of that is any of that changing your
feelings on any of that or do you think
there's any more of a gray area there so
I haven't seen much of it but what I
will say is all of that should be
transparent they should release all of
it I think it's important I think the
courts need to see it I think the press
needs to see it I think the American
people need to see it and if someone
broke the law they should go to jail and
if someone didn't break the law they
should not go to jail I mean we need to
just open it up for everybody to see
it's weird how so many people in the
media are screaming that these tapes are
being released it's like well this is
public knowledge say more than anybody
should in the old days isn't that what
they liked right they more than anybody
would always complain if things weren't
released the problem is they just wanted
it released to a committee that was
biased that didn't want the American
people to see everything if you truly
believe that you know January 6 was a
terrible day I think it was a horrible
day we never want to see that happen
again but if you truly believe that
certain things happen show us show
everybody let us see it it will help
your group case but if you're not
showing it then you're making us wonder
why are you not showing it so I think
it's good for that to get out so I
actually don't want to focus on on the
former president too much but one one
more on that which is so if you if you
felt that he was the right guy then
obviously you don't feel that he's the
right guy now which is why you're
running so what what's your thought
process I told him when I called him I
think that the country needs to go in a
New Direction I think it's time for new
generational change and I think we need
to leave the drama of the past alone and
I think for the sake of our kids we've
got to start looking forward I mean look
at the foreign policy situation and tell
me that we don't really need to be
strong and at the top of our game and
move forward look at our economy and
tell me that we don't need to be
completely focused on where we're going
to go we can't keep talking about the
past we got to get past that how much of
it you meant to I mean we've talked
about the age thing before but is is an
actual sort of generational mind shift
meaning that the Boomers have been
running this forever basically you and I
are gen xers like it's supposed to be
someone let's say roughly between 40 and
60. I mean look at DC
us like that's why I'm so desperate for
term limits like you know they say
experience matters yes but then it you
know experience turns into Power term
limits keep that from turning into power
and and turning into thin skin and hurt
feelings and thinking that you know
one-upping somebody that's what's
happened in DC now I mean what has
Congress done for you lately nothing not
much and so what I think is get fresh
faces get fresh voices get normal people
in there that can talk about what
Americans are really going through and I
think this is a time of we have to look
at forward-thinking Solutions the new
things you know the old conversations of
defense was Land Air sea right now you
got to add cyber to that you gotta add
artificial intelligence to that we've
got to have people prepare to do that
absolutely yeah so all right so let's
talk about a foreign policy a little bit
because I feel like that's sort of your
your is that your specialty can I say
that's right there
Governor so I ran a state so I mean I
can talk about the economy I can talk
about debt I can talk about pensions but
I can talk about foreign policy so you
pick it okay fair enough so you were the
U.S ambassador to the U.N under for a
couple years that things were pretty
freaking good and there were peace deals
signed and there weren't all these crazy
Wars and all of this stuff your basic
policy is piece through strength right
is that is that fair to say absolutely
and you know you look now what's going
wrong I mean first of all you look at
the fact that everything goes back to
Afghanistan I mean it's really you know
as a military spouse you know military
families sacrifice a lot Michael
deployed to Afghanistan the idea that we
left Bagram Air Force Base in the middle
of the night without telling our allies
who stood shoulder to shoulder with us
for decades
I mean is Unthinkable because that sent
a message to our friends it sent a
bigger message to our enemies what did
you just say to our military families I
mean Michael will tell you you wanted to
get out of Afghanistan fine but it's not
what you do it's how you did it there's
a reason we've got the highest suicide
right now of veterans it was the biggest
slap in the in the face and we lost 13
more soldiers because of it how worried
are you about the military in general
that there's been such a demoralization
and just that the woke thing has so
infected it and they're talking about
gender roles more than they're talking
about you know battle preparedness and
all that there is nothing that scared
Russia China and Iran more than a
America having a strong military strong
militaries don't start or strong
militaries prevent Wars we need to be
focused on how can we have the strongest
military not what they're doing right
now which is taking gender pronoun
classes that's the problem is we don't
have our eye on the ball and Russia and
China see that I mean there's the idea
that we are this week they saw what
happened in Afghanistan I mean did you
ever think Americans would look to the
sky and see a Chinese spy balloon
looking back at them
that was total arrogance and don't think
it flew over South Carolina hours you
can't go across and China watch just
watch it go across and it didn't go over
South Carolina because it loves our
beaches it went over South Carolina
because we're a military State they knew
exactly what they were doing if we did a
spy balloon over China do you think they
would have let that happen
it was a national embarrassment and so
that and then all of a sudden Russia
goes and has you know takes down one of
our drones
it is not what happens to you it's how
you respond to it and America has been
asleep at the wheel we've handed China
things on a silver platter we're letting
Russia run Rogue and we're not doing
enough about it all right so let's talk
about the the Russia Ukraine situation
because I because I think you and I have
a slightly different approach on this
and uh we played a couple of the clips
last week when Tucker had all of you you
know the potentials uh submit you know
basically your your policy or at least
your sort of overview on what you think
should happen with Ukraine
where from where I'm at at this point
even though I fully believe in peace
through strength it seems to me we're so
screwed up at the moment and financially
so out of whack and we're watching the
banks melt down and we'll talk about
that in a little bit too that this sort
of endless pouring of money to Ukraine
where we don't know where it's going
seems really nuts to me that and that
would be my first position on all of
this before we get to anything about
territory or anything else what do you
think about just that position first
we're completely out of whack and it's
like how can we help anybody we can
barely own we should never send money
yeah to any country because I don't
think you unless you know exactly where
it's going we should never send money we
I don't want to put troops on the ground
what we do need to do is make sure that
we give Ukraine what they need to win
with the allies and this is why it's
important it's not about Ukraine this is
about a war on freedom and it's one we
have to win because if we win this
this sends a message to China it sends a
message to Iran it sends a message to
Russia it sends a message to North Korea
if we lose the lesson is dictators tell
you exactly what they're going to do
Russia has said Poland and the baltics
are next
we are trying to prevent a World War
this is in the National Security
interests of Americans so if you go and
you have a dictator go and take over a
freedom-loving country
if we don't fight for that
are we that arrogant to think that we're
not next or that any of our other allies
aren't next the problem with people not
wanting to spend time on Russia is that
the exact same kind of thinking that got
us in the situation that we're in with
China right now is you if you don't show
strength to them
they will continue to push and push and
push and I dealt with the Russians and
the Chinese they think the West are the
great Sinners there is nothing they want
more than to take us down and you can't
give Russian itch because if you give
them an itch which is exactly what
they've seen happen they're going to go
and take down our drones just like they
did and violate international law so
what does a wind actually look like
because it seems to me that Putin knows
if he loses like he's done he's going to
end up like Gaddafi so he does have
nukes I mean what what does a win
actually look like at the end of this
thing so speaking of losing let's look
at where he is right now
how low has he got that he's getting
drones from Iran and missiles from North
Korea that's as bad as it gets he knows
that that they've raised the draft age
to 65. the idea that last week they
didn't have enough ammunition that they
pulled people off the streets put them
on the front line with shovels that's
where Russia has gotten to he knows that
he's in a bad spot but the one thing
he's hoping is that China will help him
there's a reason he did China's Dirty
Work by taking down that drone he's
trying to help China and China and
Russia have said we are unlimited
partners
and they have said Iran is their junior
partner that is your axis of Evil if we
don't look at that with clear lenses and
see it for what it is and be at the top
of our game on that that's what's going
to go wrong all Russia has to do for a
win is leave
is leave if Ukraine stops they lose
their entire country if Russia stops the
war is over so you may literally leave
all the territory leave Crimea like the
whole thing or that is sort of a
foregone conclusion well first of all
Obama never should have opened that door
but Dave if somebody came and took Texas
would you say okay we'll let him have
taxes think about it from the Ukrainian
standpoint California I would let them
out I know everybody says that but think
about it from the Ukrainian standpoint
this is their country I mean the idea
that these men went to the front lines
to fight for their freedom even though
they were given five days the idea that
women said I'm not going to stand by and
they made Molotov cocktails these people
have put everything on the line for
their freedom and their country that
used to be us we used to fight for our
country like that
why would we not be there I'm the first
one to say we should have the backs of
our allies and we should hold our
enemies to account if you want to talk
about what we shouldn't be doing
last year we gave 46 billion dollars in
foreign aid
now when I was at the U.N and we moved
the embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem I
was so mad at that vote because we had
the right to put our Embassy wherever we
wanted I went to my staff and I said I
want you to do a book I said I want you
to list all 193 countries I want the
second column to be the percentage of
times they vote with the U.S and against
the U.S and I want the last column to be
how much foreign aid we give them I took
that book and I gave it to president
Trump he lost his mind flipping pages
and what I said is I'm not saying you
give foreign aid based on a percentage
vote at the U.N but that should be one
of the things we do of that 46 billion
that Congress approved that was signed
last year
we're giving money to Pakistan that was
harboring terrorists trying to kill our
soldiers that's now an ally of China
we're giving money to Iraq that's right
there with Iran terrorists that are
saying death to America we're giving
money to Belarus it's holding Russia's
hand that's never been friendly to
America you're giving money to Zimbabwe
it's the most anti-afric anti-American
African country out there you're giving
money to Cuba that we labeled as a state
sponsor of terrorism we're giving money
to China
stop giving money to countries that hate
America that's not what you do we
believe in Freedom you can't buy off
enemies you can't buy all friends
the best way to show strength is to quit
all the nonsense don't give China money
that's the weakest thing you could ever
do were you shocked how quickly
countries kind of came into line once
you guys shut off some of the money
because you did do that last time and
then suddenly or when you were
Ambassador and then suddenly countries
kind of were behind us again I think if
you look at what Trump did which was he
was everybody's got to do their part
they need to pay their part in NATO they
need to do I think that was the right
message because everybody needs to pull
their weight they can't just be America
only but the other thing is we made sure
that they knew what we were for I
personally went in and made sure that at
the U.N that those countries knew what
America was for and what America was
against I didn't care if they didn't
like me but I wanted them to respect
America and one of those things that we
were talking to president talk about we
were giving 2 billion in military aid to
Pakistan
we stopped giving that military aid
Congress has now put it back in the
thing is you've got to look at that and
say let's be smart
even if it's helping a small country if
it's a win-win you do it you treat it
like a business
it's a win-win you do it if not we could
use that money here in America we don't
have to give it away and so you know
when you look at Ukraine
you know I don't want you giving a check
to Ukraine and by the way there was no
better Ally we had at the United Nations
than Ukraine they were with us on
everything I never had to ask they were
the one country that no matter what I
did they were standing by our side
always
so when you've got a country like that
just is trying to protect democracy and
freedom
you go and you fight for all the
freedom-loving countries because these
dictators want to destroy any ounce of
Freedom that exists in this world so as
long as we're talking about dollars
abroad let's do dollars here I mean it's
been a very bizarre week with banking we
aren't just so the audience knows we're
taping this a couple days before we're
going to air it so God only knows what's
going to happen you know in the next
three days or whatever it is uh but you
know Silicon Valley Bank Falls now
Signature Bank we're doing this bailout
you know my sense is that most
Republicans are kind of like uh bailout
again like this didn't work in 2008
we're just making things bigger on the
other hand you want payrolls to be met
and you don't want to punish the average
person
where do you fall out the accountant in
me always goes back and says how did we
get to this point you know you first
have to ask yourself that and then you
say okay where do we go how we got to
this point if you flush that much money
into the economy
inflation is going to happen
there was free money this was a bubble
waiting to happen talk to any of the
Wall Street Elite they will tell you
this was the easiest money they ever
made so then you go and you have all
these people
with free money
doing all of these loans that they did
and then all of a sudden what happens
the inflation goes up so high because
Congress spent all of this money
and then now you've got svb where they
bought short and they invested long and
in these bonds the interest rates going
up and then now all of a sudden there's
a loss
but the question and all that so first
of all you have to blame you know
Republicans that started you've got to
blame Biden for continuing it and
Congress to continue that then you look
at the ball that started rolling but
look at where the rub is svb isn't like
your typical Bank
94 of the money that was in that bank
was not insured
where was the San Francisco fed
like when you it all of this was
transparent they could see it so when
you see a bank is starting to buy short
but invest long and interest rates are
going up where were they where were the
Regulators so now you're going to see
members of Congress
come and say oh we have to put
regulations on or we have to do this no
where was the oversight and does anybody
find it wrong that the CEO of svb sat on
the San Francisco fed board
or that Gavin Newsom it's now coming out
that his Wineries and it sounds like his
personal accounts too were there and he
was lobbying Joe Biden for the bailout I
mean I mean well nothing with Cali
surprises me I suppose so if you want to
talk about blame I would I would say go
there so now where do we go from here
this is the socialism creep that I am
saying is happening in our country the
idea you're going to take from this
group of people to pay off this group of
people is wrong and I know that they're
saying oh but we fired management and
and that you know the bondholders lost
everything and these are the depositors
you know what we don't reward bad
management we don't reward when things
go wrong if a small business went out
who's going to save them who's going to
bail them out I was opposed to the bank
bailouts in 2008.
I was I have always been opposed to
bailouts it is a socialist creep that's
dangerous and all of these Wall Street
Elites that say oh but you know all the
other Banks were going to fall yeah
they've always said this guy's gonna
fall no it's not you know what all the
other banks will take notice and realize
what you can't do and so what they
should and instead no one's talking
about the Chinese money that was in that
bank so do you mean to tell me that our
consumers who are now having to pay
higher Bank fees and get less Services
because of it
are going to bail out the Chinese
companies
right so to be clear you you would have
just said let them fail absolutely I
mean this is not one everybody will say
the sky is falling they said it in 2008
you cannot govern like that because if
you go and you give them a pass yeah the
next Bank thinks they can do it too and
no one's pointing the fingers at the
real group that needs to be held
responsible for doing this with yes it
was management but where was the
oversight where was the FED in all this
what was their role in all this is in a
way is that like the the biggest reason
to drain the swamp that people think oh
we could just put enough Regulators in
these things and then everyone will
behave properly and blah blah blah but
it's like no one's arguing we don't well
I guess somebody is but like no one I
think sort of roughly Centrist would say
there aren't enough regulators and
that's what caused the problem so that's
why you have to drain the swamps and the
amazing thing is they're going to say oh
but we need more regulation or this
wouldn't have happened no you don't need
more regulation you actually need to
just go say who was in charge of it and
why didn't they do their job so and
where was the outrage before this
happened because they all could see it
so I happen to be more on this side of
the argument too because otherwise I
just see this as endless creep we'll
just bail out everybody no one will ever
be responsible and then we'll end up
with one bank which will be the United
States that will ensure everybody
endlessly but if you were a president
right now and that bank failed and you
found out that I don't know how many
companies but let's say 100 companies
that they were that were doing their
banking there now you've all of these
people who were just the employees at
the companies who are now all lot of
work because their checks are going to
bounce does the government have any
responsibility to those people anywhere
this is where it always pushes that's
that push and pull of small government
don't fall for it government was
intended to secure the rights and
freedoms of the people it was never
meant to be all things to all people
that's it so when you go and you decide
to work for someone you never know if
they're going to go bankrupt if you go
and you decide to put your money
somewhere all of these clients at svb
these were not your normal loans right
they were they had really stretched it
in a big way they knew what they were
doing these were you know risky tech
companies that knew exactly what they
were getting loans they couldn't get
from any other bank and they knew
exactly what they were getting into no
you don't change the rules you change
the accountability that that should have
been there and you hold people
accountable that's how you fix things is
the problem more of an Optics thing so
it's like then Biden comes in and he
says okay everyone's going to have their
money and it's like the average person
is like oh Joe Biden saved the day
everyone will have their money but in
reality that's not really a real leader
communicates the facts on the ground a
real leader tells you the truth that's
the problem we're not seeing we're not
getting the truth we're not getting the
truth on spending we're not getting the
truth on the bailout we're not getting
the truth with this foreign policy no
one's telling the truth and sometimes
the truth hurts but guess what if you
tell the truth you're quicker to get to
a solution you want to know why this
country is so divided nobody's telling
the truth yeah
and Americans want the truth that's all
they want life is hard enough just tell
them the truth and they'll know how to
make decisions from there I use the
Socialists and quote on the show every
day all we have to do is stop
participating in the lie that's it but
it seems like everyone is lying all I
mean that's basically all I do every
morning I'm like all right who lied
today let's go through 20 people that
just can't tell the truth will that in a
way be the hardest part of running for
president that you know no matter what
you say and any any of you guys on this
side of the aisle they're basically
going to make it up and you got to just
keep slogging through that no I mean
that's part of it you know politics is a
blood sport you don't get in if you
can't you know take the heat yes they're
going to cut things up yes they're going
to tell lies yes they're going to say
things that's already happened that's
happened you know throughout my
political life but my job is to just
keep communicating what I believe what
my truth is there's rumors out there
about all kinds of things like what I
believe on this issue or that issue I'll
just you know I'll clearly tell you what
it is and then people read is there
something that you think is like the
biggest miscommunication about you or
something that you think no I think it's
I think most recently the funny thing is
that um
that CNN did this article and said oh
she wants to cut off you know Social
Security and Medicare and the truth is
yes we do have to do entire and that's
what I said I said you if you're going
to be honest
you know yes we call back the 500 yes we
go after the 100 fraud yes we stop
borrowing yes we cut the spending yes we
cut the earmarks but you have to talk
about entitlement reform and the way you
talk about it is we don't take from
anybody that was promised don't touch
seniors don't touch anyone that has put
money in that has been promised my
parents are in their 80s I don't want
anybody taking from them but my kids are
in their 20s and you go to them and you
say the game has changed for you because
they know they're not going to get it
anyway let's start there start with
everyone in their 20s coming into the
system and let's let's do a few things
one let's raise their retirement age so
that we actually are looking more at
life expectancy let's go and change cost
of living to relate more to inflation
instead of just a cost of living let's
go and let's make sure we expand
Medicare Advantage plans so you have
more competition you run down costs
those are the things that we could do
that would really make a difference if
we did that let's go and limit the
benefits that go to the wealthy because
you can talk to people like Bernie
markets they'll tell you I don't want it
but let's go ahead and limit that so you
know these are truths that we have to
acknowledge don't run from it because of
what CNN says just go out there and
educate on why you think what you think
so I want to get into some of the people
you'll be running against on the
Republican side but to quickly kind of
do the Democrat thing I mean is it a bit
of an odd thing that you kind of don't
know who you're running against because
to your point it's like Biden has this
really been like what is going on there
I mean what what do you really make of
what's happening with him and who's in
charge and all that I mean look I I
think that you know it's easy to know
that Susan Rice is still in that white
house and that the old Obama crew is
still there but Biden has done an
amazing job at becoming much more
Progressive I mean than anybody ever
thought he would be I think you're
looking at Biden and Kamala that's who
we're looking at that's what you have to
assume if Biden isn't still there Kamala
is going to be the one in there and I'm
not okay with any of that yeah it'd be
kind of fun to run against her I feel
like that would be at least a little
more fun for you like the Biden thing
it's like how do you make sense I mean
that's fun too because you look at I
mean when you've got such a low bar I
mean that's not a bad thing so all right
so let's talk about some of the the
people that you'll be running against on
the Republican side because everyone I
think is trying to jockey for you know
what separates us all on these things so
first off I mean you could be on a
debate stage with your former boss
um do you Relish in that do you do you
you know I mean that seems to be where
he shines like what do you make of
having to do that I shine on a debate
stage too I mean it's just a fact you
know we're both running we're both going
to be on a debate stage he's my friend
but you know at the end of the day do we
have different styles in different ways
yeah I think that's going to show
and what about the guy here in Florida I
live in Florida now my life is
immeasurably better as you know because
of that like to me he's done basically
everything right we don't know if he's
running
um it sounds like there'll be a little
bit of a foreign policy difference with
you guys according to the Tucker thing
for sure but a lot of the other stuff
kind of seems similar what do you make
of that um well I saw your statement
actually you just put out a statement
that basically he's copying Trump on a
lot of this stuff I mean he's been a
good governor and I think that you know
I'm a fan of Governors I think Governors
know what it means to run something they
understand how to deal with a crisis
they understand how to deal with a
budget there's a lot to be said about a
governor you know the only thing I'll
say is that you know watching him
like he took a did a total 180 and
switched on where he was on entitlements
and is now where Trump is
he did a total 180 on where he is with
Ukraine and is now where the Trump is so
it just comes across like a trump Echo
well you know then there's no difference
between the two of them could some of
that just be being in office and how
things change I I'm not going to assume
to know what he's thinking why he's
thinking it I just think that it's odd
that he is literally saying the exact
same things as Trump I mean you see like
the same things are coming out and I
think Americans when they look at it
that were the case they just vote for
Trump they're not looking for an Echo
they're looking for like
for for options but you know he's got to
decide where he's going to be on
everything I think you have to be honest
with the American people and say yes
you've got to acknowledge entitlement
reforms but there's a way to do it I
think you've got to be honest on you
know foreign policy that look if you are
going to be weak in the knees on Russia
you're going to end up with Russia being
just like China we've watched that have
we had Republicans and Democrats that
got weak in the knees on China and said
oh just leave them if we're nice to them
they'll want to be like us that is why
we are in this situation where they are
stealing intellectual property they're
now in our universities they're buying
up our Farmland they're sending spy
balloons up in the air it all started
with people saying you don't need to
worry about time let's just worry about
us well you start doing that with Russia
and now you're going to have China and
Russia there so actually instead of with
our remaining time going through the the
laundry list of people that are running
I think those are the big two so your
feelings are clear on that I just want
to ask you sort of philosophically I
think one of the things that I'm seeing
Bubble Up Now constantly is that the
people feel that the machine itself that
the the way the United States was
constructed cannot work at a federal
level that the states are so out of
whack with each other and that I fled
California that I I truly see no hope
for after the last time I was in San
Francisco I mean it is it barely looks
like an American city it looks like a
third world country basically and then I
see how things are flourishing here that
there really is a feeling amongst a
certain set of people on the right like
actually the the United part of this
thing is not going to work anymore and
that we should only focus on the states
what do you what do you think about that
I'm a state's rights girl you know I
mean I think that you know as a governor
I think that the majority of control
should always be in the states I mean
look the federal government it breaks
more than it fixes we see that every day
so you know as president my goal is
going to be to empower the states as
much as possible whether it's health
care whether it's education whether it's
military whether it's all of those
things it's best when it's closest to
the people that's when government runs
the best when you have these Behemoth
agencies that get so bloated and so big
and then try and dictate to everybody
what they should do I think that's part
of the problem we've got to clean it out
what does that mean like to like because
I think there's going to be a
competition for you guys to basically
blow apart every agency I can see it
happening on stage how many of you will
blow apart the department of Ed how many
apartment like EPA blah blah blah I mean
is that what you'd go for like really
just like disassembling these things so
what I did in South Carolina was I made
sure that I put people in charge of
those agencies and put people within
those agencies their job was to clean it
up get rid of the red tape get rid of
the rid of the bureaucracy get rid of
the people who had been there too long
that had created these power fiefdoms
and just and some agencies it required
really cleaning house and some it
required tweaks but you don't know you
know once you get in there but you have
to assume they all are bloated and they
all have it and it should be a number
one priority that you do day one that
that's in there and that's the number
one rule because if you don't have a
government that works for the people
then you've just got a government that
works for
power and that's what you don't want the
second part is we've got to get to a
place where as much as I love term
limits
within bureaucracy you've got to roll
people over no one should stay in the
same job for 20 or 30 years is that in
essence what the Deep State when people
say deep state is that what they mean
more than anything else it's just the
bureaucratic layer of these people that
are sort of never moving in these
agencies so the president comes and goes
but these guys are 40 years in doing the
same thing and making an awful lot of
money doing it well you know it's like
when I was at the United Nations and I
was going my first speech was actually
hitting Russia on what they were doing
with Ukraine at the time of the whole
Crimea thing and so
um when I went in you know I drafted my
speech I was ready to go I sent it to
the state department you know just in
National Security Council so they could
look it over they call back all upset
saying you can't say this and I said
well what part you know can't what parts
factually incorrect they said well none
of it's factually incorrect but you
can't talk like this
and I said okay if you've got an issue
or a fact that is wrong I am the first
one to want to fix it
but you can't tell me how to say
something and I just ignored them and I
went forward but that's kind of they
want you to do it their way they want
you to do things but you know the reason
that I was able to do so much in the
United Nations was I went in with fresh
eyes
you know I went in and really wanted to
break what needed to be broken and see
it through a different lens and I've
never held office in DC but I think that
same thing needs to happen you've got to
go in and not have allegiances to
anything you've got to build up build
the trust back up I mean Americans don't
trust any agency yeah and so the number
one goal of a leader is Americans should
at least trust what these agencies are
telling them and if they're so big and
so bureaucratic and so powerful
something's wrong with the system
would you say that's all a result of
just sort of bipartisan bad policy or is
that really just this you know we did 50
some odd minutes we haven't said the
word woke once like is it just that
wokeness has now infected everything and
all of the wrong people are being hired
for all of the wrong thing all the wrong
reasons and nobody's qualified to do any
of this this was before any of the
wokeness this was the fact that you know
I saw this in South Carolina agencies
think that if they're going to get the
same budget next year they have to spend
everything that they have and we put
them it's true right it's not just that
they think it it's actually true that's
true I wish I could remember I would go
into agencies and there would be closets
of computers and printers and everything
they would do and so we started
incentivizing agencies to give money
back to the taxpayers so you know when
you go in there what they do is oh we
need more people for this we need more
people for that you add a new program
that's not adding a person that's adding
25 more people that's the growth of
government and so at some point you go
into every agency you look at every
program and say what was the intent is
it still needed I did that in the United
Nations I went into every single
um one of the peacekeeping operations we
had and I said what was the original
intent
are we complaining and what's our exit
strategy because they had no exit
strategies to any of them we saved three
billion dollars the first year it's just
about putting some good approaches in
place that make sure that they're
actually meeting the intended goal to
start with and if there is no goal
anymore you scrap that program you scrap
the people that go with it and that's
how you clean an agency and then you go
and you put in something or anybody
that's in a role they can only serve in
it four to five years and then they roll
to a different position or another
position you never let them sit for that
long so speaking of the un uh quickly
um is it weird to you how irrelevant the
UN is now I mean it almost is like in
complete conjunction with you leaving
like the U.N is no one talks about the
U.N they don't it doesn't seem like they
meet anymore does the security Council
do anything do they even know what's
happening in Russia like what is the U.N
at this point except that they rack up a
lot of Apartments the U.N is a farce
I've said that for a long time but it
what's interesting you say that is I was
meeting with Prime Minister Modi and
India
um back when I was at the UN and we were
talking about at the time their
alliances
you know their military cooperation with
Russia at the time and he said do you
know I never paid attention to the
United Nations until you were there
but the reason that was the case was it
wasn't about me specifically it was
about the fact that I forced them to
talk about things that were
uncomfortable to talk about I forced
them to deal with issues of the day and
not old archaic things and I called them
out when they were doing something wrong
and you know just said why aren't we
talking about Russia why aren't we
talking about the chemical weapons in
Syria why aren't we talking about the
Iran deal and how they're violating I
just forced them to talk about things
that were uncomfortable
and I think that we need to have some
uncomfortable conversations in this
country too speaking of forcing someone
to talk about uncomfortable things I
mean who are you going to choose as your
VP how about that come on no I'll let
you know we'll figure it out at the time
but it'll be somebody that makes the
team stronger that's for sure
do you have any other final thoughts I
think we've we've covered most of the
stuff I wanted to hit here I think the
main thing is everybody needs to put all
of this
division
in its place and understand we're
fighting for our country that's what
this is about every American has to
fight for the survival of our country
and in order to fight for the survival
of anything you have to love it we have
to go back to loving America we have to
go back to love the principles of
America capitalism has lifted up more
people than any place in the world we
don't need to go into this socialism we
need to quit quit beating down you know
America you when I was I always tell the
story because I think it's fascinating
when I was on the Simon Boulevard bridge
in South America
you saw thousands of people going from
Venezuela to Colombia holding their kids
walking for hours in the hot sun to get
to one meal they might get that day they
were killing zoo animals for food
and when we got to the Catholic Church
they all started coming around me
and at first I was like why do they care
about who I am and then it hit me they
didn't care who I was they cared where I
was from
in me they saw America and in America
they saw hope
we need to appreciate our blessings we
need to remember what my parents always
told my brothers and my sister and me
was even on our worst day we are blessed
to live in America now we have to fight
for so everybody wants to talk about
this political side don't complain about
what happens in a general if you don't
play in this primary play in this
primary see America the way it should be
want more for your family and our kids
and our education and our military and
our foreign policy we deserve better we
deserve better and if we all commit to
it we'll get better but that's what it's
going to take
well then I guess I can only end this
with one last thing which is I sense
your future will be brighter than Don
Lemon so it's gonna all be okay go to
nikkihaley.com
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell